hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
so excited to have the absolutely lovely
hailey cali here uh she's a sports
illustrated swimsuit model but before
that she was working as an immunologist
in a
god i'm going to call it a science lab
you know she studied medical biology
psychology chemistry all of that took a
chance entering the sports illustrated
swimsuit contest online got a dm from
them and then her world took off from
there she's
so lovely and hyper intelligent and so
fun to talk to and is really trying to
combat the stigma of the model
stereotype which i admire so much she
also has launched the nerd herd
a foundation empowering young women in
stem we talk all about that we talk
about the wild world of modeling uh the
pageants that she did in minnesota when
she was younger it is she's just so
lovely and she's also a gamer we talk
about love island all of it enjoy this
episode of not too deep with haley kelly
[Music]
okay haley i
uh
i need to know your life story okay i'm
just gonna put it that bluntly i am so
fascinated by
um you're the way you grew up and where
you are now um well one you're a
professional model now uh
and also i i like a entrepreneur you
have a foundation now you have many
things going on but it didn't start that
way
um
can you give us like uh
how you've gotten to where you're at
right now
yeah i have a very different path into
like the modeling world than most girls
yeah most of my girlfriends started at
12 and they were scouted in this mall or
they're in denmark modeling agent what's
up that's not me like you look at my old
pictures from middle school elementary
school high school i was the last person
in the world to get scouted and i was
cool with that that was totally fine so
i always grew up as the daughter of two
engineers that's a huge huge nerd like i
was always the nerdy
class focused like had to get nate fuss
had to beat everyone out yeah so school
was really my main focus growing up grew
up in minnesota then from there went on
to university studied biomedical
sciences with a minor in chem so kept
with the nerd saying just a just an easy
schooling situation for yourself yeah
you like to take it easy
easy my parents love to just give me the
easiest things to study it's great i'm
sure but then i took a chance and i
thought you know what i've always been
interested in modeling since i grew up
in the 90s and the 90s were like peak
performance of models cindy crawford and
mcpherson stunning and so i submitted to
sports illustrated social casting call
which they held their first ever one
where you submitted an instagram video
and i literally sat here like this just
put my phone right here and i was like
hey what's up guys i'm haley cleo um i'd
really love to be in your issue and if
you don't choose me that's cool too but
like what's up and then uh i remember
two weeks later i mean i had no
followers at this time yeah i had like
maybe 50 followers and they were like my
aunt and my dad yes
dedicated followers
dedicated just my biggest fan and sports
illustrated split into my dms
and i remember the exact moment because
i literally like collapsed to the ground
and i was like this cannot be happening
right now like this is not my like those
one of those moments forever
and then that started my modeling
journey the first thing that i ever shot
in my modeling journey was sports
illustrated swimsuit which
is iconic true and now here i am living
in new york full-time model i work with
my foundation and
oh my whole life changed okay let's
break this down a little bit
because this is such a whirlwind
wild story
and the fact that you did like you said
both your parents were engineers you
grew up in like academia and that whole
world
um but you you also did
um pageants right
i did scholarship money
oh okay so talk to you about this
because i in doing some research your
first pageant was when you were like 16
years old
so i was 17 i really no i competed in
miss minnesota teen usa back when i was
16. so i used to watch yeah tell me
about tell me about how you even did
this i'm so because i did miss new
jersey when i was like in college
on a full whim total academic nerd but
was just like i'm curious in this and so
i'm so fascinated by how you got into it
interested signed up etc
so
i'm gonna throw my dad under the bus
here but
i used to watch pageants with my dad and
my dad watched pageants because
obviously beautiful women i watched
pageants because i was like these women
are so cool like these women they're so
coy virgins they're so confident boys
they can answer some questions about
politics that like at the age of 12 was
like i don't even know what like
international diplomacy is and this is a
question
i mean they were incredible they were
such inspirations to me so when i talked
to my parents i was like listen i want
to do this and both my parents were like
there's no way in heck you're never
doing this and then i said well there's
a scholarship money aspect so
no student loans you know i can pay for
my entire college and they were sold on
that so i entered my first pageant was
miss minnesota teen usa i had no clue
what i was doing i bought a 60 dollar
dress i had no training i showed up i
like doing my own makeup i was standing
on that stage like this when all the
rest of the girls like we're like this i
mean the photos are hilarious it's not
like going out in history because
they're my worst photos i'm like
and i loved it i felt so confident i
felt so beautiful and so i tried it
again the next year put a little more
training into it studied it a little bit
and then ended up winning
when we went to nationals had no clue
what i was doing again and then
totally lost it ashley totally bumped
but the best time in my life got the
scholarship honey and then i continued
with miss minnesota usa it was a bigger
scholarship money package and they
helped me pay for almost my entire
university
wow
and so okay what i mean obviously you're
good at studying it sounds like across
the board in every category but when
you're going okay i did this
i looked around people knew more than
what i did how do you go back and like
study for something like that to be like
i'm gonna do it again i'm gonna do it
better this time
i insta-stocked all of the girls that
were good at cabinets i was like let me
just scream a little bit and then i just
watched they would like move their hand
it would twist things pages
oh
yes so i just i like playing on repeat
and practice
like oh i'm so points like look at her
versus like the tomboy knees down you
know like this the year before so i just
studied them which they don't know that
i creeped on them as much as i did but i
studied it and studying works amazing i
mean yeah that's what you have to do
that's so incredible and i'm so
fascinated um
and then so how long was it between
doing
pageants to before you sent in a
submission to sports illustrated oh man
it was my entire college career pretty
much so i did miss teen usa back in high
school so that was my senior year of
high school
usa
i got the scholarship money went to
college i think it was my second year of
college that i decided i wanted to try
and miss usa to take the rest of my
college so i tried that enjoyed the
entire experience um didn't
um and then after that it was just
focusing on academics because i had
always wanted to be a doctor so when i
was focused on studying for my mcat i
was focused on getting through biochem
organic chem immunology and then after i
graduated i went and worked in an
immunology lab for a short period of
time and that was when i submitted my
video for sports illustrated swimsuit
okay what was being
an immunologist is that the correct term
what what's that like
so immunology is the study of cellular
tissue so what our lab focused on in the
study of type 1 diabetes and in small
farm towns in minnesota there's a high
preference of children born with type 1
diabetes yeah and we in our lab thought
oh it might be because of this inorganic
pollutant that was used in the 60s that
might have increased the prevalence so
we did this entire study on it
and found zero correlation but hey
finding nothing is combining something
yes exactly that's conclusive at least
exactly so we were published like we
wanted words that are our published huge
wonderful like it was amazing to have in
my resume it was an incredible
experience working in the lab working
with my lab partners they were all
incredibly intelligent people i mean
they can't even say enough good things
about them and um then i quit my job and
started becoming a model yeah and so you
pivot to this completely new world which
i guess you have some idea of because of
like the pageant world i wonder how much
that maybe maps over into that world um
if at all or if maybe the lab maps over
more than the pageant world does i i
think they kind of both for pageants for
me i was always a kid that was super
insecure growing up just because i was
teased so much for being like the nerdy
quirky kid like yeah i was the kid with
one best friend where like you wouldn't
get invited to the birthday party
so i think pageants threw me into a
world where i was surrounded with all of
these beautiful people and i needed to
feel comfortable with who i was because
everywhere i looked there was this
stunningly gorgeous accomplished woman
and so i needed to be okay with who i
was and it's the same in modeling like
you walk into a casting and it's a room
full of some of the most beautiful
people you've ever seen in your life
and if you let those negative like
headspace thoughts get in there of like
i'm not gonna she's pretty or she's
gonna get this job you're just you're
dead in the water so i think
pageants definitely helped me in the
confidence side of things and then as
far as academia and working in the lab i
think that helped me view myself as more
than just this because in the modeling
world you're you're a hank and you
sometimes brands give you a platform
that sports illustrated that wants you
to speak on things that you love other
brands which that's what modeling is
just want to use you as a hanger and
there's nothing wrong with that since
that's the job but it made me find worse
in this versus this
so they both made me who i am today
which i'm very thankful for
it's very interesting because i do think
you know with with social media um and
you know the advent of like being able
to
be a more complex person online and like
fully show every different side of you
uh which before like i remember growing
up with like the models that you were
talking about like all of them
uh on runways that you just saw them as
beautiful people and then when they
started to be like quote allowed to have
personalities was just like oh my god
and now you have like the hadids and all
of these like you know victoria's secret
models that have built these social
media file and like you know the the
genders of it all have built these like
social media followings as like fully
formed human beings and literally
classes of it all that have like been
able to be um
as nerdy or as whatever as they want i'm
curious like
with that because social media is such a
big thing what's your kind of like um
relationship with social media is it a
love hate is it a love love is it a uh
otherwise
it's um i think with everybody it's a
little bit of a love hate just because
in social media i mean you're in social
media you get
positive but you also get a lot of
uninvited negative so you have to be
really confident in who you are because
it's like there's this tick tock that is
one of my favorite takeouts of all time
and it's this person scrolling through
their comments on social media and it's
like all these negative comments and
they're like oh man a new insecurity
like didn't know my eyes were too far
apart but now i guess i do yeah
social media is a great way to show
people who i am and that's kind of the
biggest part of my brand is i want
people to know i'm just so normal i am a
normal human i go through the same stuff
as everyone else like at a normal job
normal like everything about me is so
normal so for them to put me on a
pedestal as a model i just want to take
away that pedestal because i don't think
it should be there a lot of just another
job it's just another job very true um
with that are there any auditions or
ghosties or whatever or jobs that you've
had that stand out as the
mo
i don't want to say bad but like
strangest or most unique situations
weirdest
i've definitely had bad castings and if
you talk to any model
and they're open about it and if they're
not good they will tell you about them
like there are times when you walk into
the room like you're all excited you got
your little comp card and you're like
think you're looking great and then you
hand them it which by the way you have
to pay for all these cop cards like
these are not free because pay for these
cards and so you're handing them this
card they'd be like this is four dollars
yeah
and they literally will put it in the
garbage in front of you
let me just rip out my heart and jump up
the building like this was great today
was great uh those have been some of my
least favorite castings but it happens
rarely because the industry is changing
thank god yeah that's yeah i feel like
there's
a lot of transparency on the industry
now which doesn't allow people to be as
um
horrible as they might have been before
without realizing it um
okay speaking of not horrible i want to
talk about nerd hurt can you tell us
about this
yes so i ever since i got involved in
modeling i've wanted to do something
with stem because now i have this
platform my 50 followers and my dad and
my uncle turned into you know a big
platform of people and i want to use it
for good i don't wanna just post like
hey here's me in a bikini cool enjoy it
um i wanna do something good and my
thing is getting young women involved in
stem i remember that i was one of four
women in my upper level physics class so
to see that shift is super important for
me and i i want to be a part of it so
the nurture kind of came about back when
i was younger i have an older sister and
you know all their sisters he loves kids
i would go to all my nerdy clubs and
she's like oh he's going off to the nerd
herd like i'll have fun with your nerd
hurt
and so that used to be a negative term
for me but now i'm like you know what
what's wrong with that like that's
awesome like nerds are out here changing
the world like elon musk that you're
going to space like that's the coolest
thing in the world and i want young
women to be passionate about it at a
young age because a lot of them are
steered away from it because it's not
considered to be an area that women
should excel in when in actuality women
are incredible at math and science
they're just turned away from it at a
young age so i started the nerd herd
to hopefully and once covet is under
control because we're still dealing with
the pandemic i love to get in the
classroom i would love to teach young
girls how to be in the lab
but engineering is just get them
interested in science because it's such
an important thing and then in
2022 because we've had some delays
because of cobin um we'll be releasing a
loungewear line where 100 of the
proceeds are going to go to an
organization called black girls code and
they help these young women involved in
stem especially in low income areas so
they're an incredible organization and
i'm so so so excited for launch amazing
i mean and that feels like a great way
to kind of combine the
split sort of thing you have going on
right now which is like modeling etc and
then academia and coding or stem and all
of that um i think that's so cool
like what's the
i don't i'm not super familiar with this
what is the like deterrent for young
women in stem is it just that it's it's
always been like a masculine field and
so there's just like this harder to get
in situation
i think
a lot of young girls think of it as very
male dominated and that's switching in
some fields like medicine for instance i
think a couple years ago it finally
switched for it was like 51
women in medical school versus
49 men but when you're going through
like let's say you're in high school and
you're in calculus yeah you know a lot
of people are gonna be like ah this
isn't like shouldn't you be in history
like shouldn't be like art you're just
more you're pushed more towards
certain things like teaching art history
yeah which isn't wrong either if you're
passionate about that go for it but i
think a lot of young women see
sciences as something that men do
and it's because men are very pushed
forward in the media as being people
that own the sciences and we're seeing
that change slowly
but it needs to change faster because
these young women are sitting there with
a passion for science like me and then a
teacher is telling you like oh you know
like you're pretty good at this for a
girl yeah and you're like
i don't i don't know what that means
that shouldn't be a thing anymore so
we're trying to change that that's
incredible um
i'm so excited for you uh okay we're
going to take a quick break when we get
back i have a bunch more questions for
you so we'll be right back with more not
today
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast uh if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you and uh second thing if you are
enjoying yourself here in this not too
deep world we've built and you'd like to
leave us a review that would be so
wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little
review comment how are you feeling good
bad otherwise maybe just good or
otherwise would be appreciated other
than that enjoy the podcast
all right haley i have a bunch more
questions for you so many uh i'm trying
to figure out where to go into
oh let's go into the two questions i ask
every single guest that's on the podcast
okay
so
the first question i ask every guest is
to tell us who alive or dead would you
most like to throw cold spaghetti at
um well i just listened to all too well
uh the ten minute version oh yeah so
what jake dylan hall i'm so sorry bud
you're getting destroyed on everything
but man taylor did a great job
so i'm sorry buddy you're getting
spaghetti on ya
okay uh no real follow-up questions
there just yet maybe we'll go back there
uh
the other question is every single guest
is to tell us your worst pant [ __ ]
story or like a bathroom emergency
situation
however
you can only use three words or like
small phrases to describe
the event
so for example
mine is college jogging front lawn
oh no mine
i love that you have one immediately oh
i have a lot
of doors
mine was
horse cam
oh um
jumping off a horse
yeah that'll do it that'll close the
door on horse camp for anyone i was like
goodbye horses
uh okay now we have a section of the
podcast called deep and hot where i ask
you a deep question that we have
prepared for you and for a hot take on
like a topic or a situation that we have
prepared for you
so
my deep question for you is because i
know that you've said in interviews
before
because you're such you have such a
academia as like your background and now
that you work in modeling
it's hard for you to get taken seriously
in that sense so the question is do you
think it's important to prove people
wrong or to know for yourself that they
just won't ever know you completely
i think it's a little bit of both
actually i think it's important as a
model who has the background that i have
kind of like what carly's doing to speak
out and to prove people wrong because we
have the resources to do so but i don't
think you should do it out of spite i
think you should do it out of
wanting to change the situation for the
better and wanting to change the
stereotype around it granted you are
never going to change everyone's mind
everyone is never going to like you and
everyone's never gonna
believe that you can change the
stereotype so it's important to try to
do it and use what you have but you're
never fully gonna change people's minds
yeah no that's um a very beautiful way
to put that especially because i think
smart models get some of the hardest
uh
circumstances to try and prove
themselves in because people are like
no i don't believe you you can show me
here you can show me your sat scores you
can show me i i'll give you this like uh
actual test right now and i'm going to
think that somehow you have cheated or
something is wrong with this like i
literally need my degree
tattooed on my forehead because i have
been at so many events where i'm they're
like what do you do for a living and i
hate i hate that question first yeah i'm
like we're more than what we do for a
living yeah but whenever i say the word
model i get such a different response
than when i used to say i worked in an
immunology lab but just the amount of
respect that you're given especially for
men is so so different yeah i remember i
was at an event and this older gentleman
asked me what you do i said i was a
model and he started talking about
modeling and then he said well why don't
you just marry a rich man that'll take
care of you and i said i don't need that
you know i i worked in the immunology
lab and i did my entire experience the
second i said that he changed his entire
narrative yeah oh wow you can go do
whatever you want and take over the
world and i was like why can't you tell
me that when i'm a model too why don't
you take this yeah that's what we're
trying to change it's a very strange
strange way that the brain shifts and
categorizes people and their limitations
based on uh previous history i guess i
don't know
yeah yeah more power to you
okay now um you've kind of touched on
this already but
the topic for your hot take because i
saw recently that this was something
that affected you emotionally is taylor
swift it is
how
uh
with what she's doing now where she's
come from and also kind of in the same
zeitgeist of like you know reclaiming
her own
everything
what are your thoughts on taylor swift
i mean i was obsessed she was my entire
high school experience yeah yeah any man
that i dated which graces
i was not many in high school it's not
such a weirdo i still am but
not much dating experience
every time i would like to have a bad
breakup or like a guy didn't get me back
instantly crank in the taylor
like it was just it was great so to see
her come back to actually own the rights
to her own songs that she wrote there is
nothing more va of a woman to be like
you know what
i own this because i created this and i
should be pocketing the money from this
because it's mine so i'm here for it i'm
like i have it on repeat also in the
bathroom as i was getting ready i'm like
reliving the terrible moments from my
high school
oh yeah it really does take you back to
a certain time in your life when you
felt scorned and you were like i don't
want to feel like this but i am
emotional and like she truly has her
finger on the emotional pulse of someone
that is going through a breakup i mean
it's oh
i remember like i had a jeep liberty
like this beat up cheek liberty that got
some from my older sister and i
specifically remember like i went on a
date with one guy that was like i was in
love with him
the second after 8 000 was like i don't
think this is going to work i got into
my jeep and i just blared
huge moment in my life
it's the anthems for all of us also did
you recently go see harry styles i did
how was that i'm obsessed
i am somebody that didn't get harry
styles at first so like yeah i would
watch tick tocks like hairstyles so much
i was like cool he's a good looking guy
like i don't get it yeah then i went to
the concert
and then i got it i was like
okay this man is just doing something
like
he is so confident in who he is he's
still like gender bending he doesn't
give a crap in the best way yeah and i
think i'm in love like it's
spiritual experience yeah i know the
fact that he is defined or redefining
categories or breaking the lines on
categories is um
like give me a man and a dress like
please like after seeing him like wear
whatever my dresses you want in my
closet like i know the photos
the photo of him as dressed as dorothy
for halloween i was like
this is the only thing that's made sense
to me lately
literally
like the world is chaos but harry styles
makes ten yes
a hundred percent
uh on that note what are you watching or
what do you do in free time how do you
spend the time that you're not working
netflix and who
okay
what are you binging
squid games i've seen it twice now so
i've watched the dubbed version first
which i think was a mistake because the
kind of version is better yeah i've only
seen the dub version yeah no watch the
undead that's just very and he seems
like a comedy yeah it seems very jarring
yeah it's it's it's interesting but the
non-dubbed version is way more intense
okay and you like learn a little bit
more about who the characters are and
then um of course i have been watching
you guys
which one
you it's about you stocks yeah yeah i
haven't gotten into that one yet okay
i'm adding that to my list i keep
forgetting about that
and you you have to get back past the
first like
three episodes in the first season
and then you start getting into it it
takes a while but it's really really
really good okay okay are you into
reality television in any capacity
you know i used to watch well i guess is
the bachelor reality television oh for
sure yeah then yes then the best that's
like one guilty pleasure like that's
like a cornerstone reality tv
like i i do oh and love island love
the uk version the uk version yes i
started last year to watch
a season of love island and it was so
wild because i've heard so much about it
and everyone builds it up so much
but i have to watch it with subtitles on
because i don't know their accents i
can't figure out they're all wonderful
and they all sound like beautiful
cartoon characters i can't tell what
they're saying i just i just love like
what they say with like a god wants it
and they're like
oh my god like i can't see
just like sit there and watch that's all
i want yeah no i would just yeah i wish
that they had like a little a tiny
little audience area where you could
just hear what they're saying i guess
that's what producers do that they said
you're going window yeah which is
totally wrong and inappropriate like
just under one of their beds
i'll be the bartender i'll be like well
son bachelor in paradise exactly
do
um
do you have like a dream
campaign or a dream job or
an area of
work that you haven't worked in yet that
you would love to get to
so one of my ones was to get a billboard
in times square and i just knocked that
off and i was like
hell yeah
um victoria's secret is
i think one of the top ones for me yeah
like
because i grew up watching
all of the angels and they're doing this
whole rebrand that i absolutely adore
where they're showing personality and
they're showing different body types and
i'd love to be a part of it so that's
kind of my my dream client because i
already worked with my dream client
which is sports illustrated
so i was gonna be
you're someone that puts your mind to
something and you get it done and so i
feel like this will happen for you at
some point
fingers crossed i try my best i try my
very best
um we're gonna take one last break when
we get back we have a question sent in
from a listener that you and i can give
some very unprofessional advice to so uh
we'll be right back with more not too
deep
[Music]
wait are you into gaming
um i dabble you dabble okay what are you
uh so one of my favorite games because
i'm so ocd is called anno 1800 okay did
you ever play roller coaster tycoon when
you were younger i have played it before
my brothers i'm middle child brother
brother older younger and so they were
super into it so i'd watch them play but
i just could never get myself to like
sit down and do it oh see this you like
i will sit and put it in quarantine for
hours on end you build a city so you
have like a cool manufacturing plant a
water plant like
you have a place where you raise cattle
like yeah this is this entire thing and
then you have like people try to attack
your city and you can sit for like 20
hours and just build
yeah they used to play sim city uh i
think which is like the
one before that but all within the same
company and i'd be like oh i have little
like warlords in my home with me that
are building our gods over their own
ecosystems right now okay
like i just literally got a discord
thing that they were like let's get it
like
this is popping up
like warzone
oh so funny
um okay haley we are going to work
together to answer a question which i
think now that i've watched was that
your husband helping you out it was yeah
okay
now that i've seen matt help you out i
think you will have some
very um
you know experience with this question
i'm so excited
uh a listener has written in and said i
just moved in with my girlfriend after
dating for three and a half years and
finding it hard to adjust to fully
sharing my space all the time and
dealing with someone else's messes do
you have any advice for first moving in
with someone and how to make it work
oh see i'm the person that they're with
i'm the messy person oh yeah i know same
thing
like my advice is gonna be terrible
because it's gonna be like don't you
love them help them clean like
like i don't know just like write them a
note and really get your crafts together
i just like yeah or start hiding like
this would work for me just start hiding
my messes so i'll just leave stuff
everywhere just start hiding my favorite
jeans or like hiding my favorite tank
top that i need in the middle of the
living room and soon i'll i'll start
putting them away because i'm like stop
touching myself yeah that's very true
very trying to end the relationship but
like she might be cleaner
that's good you're gambling with some
relationship stuff but it could be
really fun i'm with you too that i'm
also a very messy person i do think when
you share your space
you both have to kind of like
know or like accept that this person
might be messy and it's not like a
personal attack on you it's just
generally the way that their brain is
operating i get very distracted very
easily and so i have like so many half
projects and half things pulled out and
i'll go okay now's the time that i
should paint this like picture frame
that i said i was going to do and then
i'll go oh wait i haven't opened the
mail yet and then i'll have to that and
then it looks like a tasmanian devil has
come through the house completely
i feel like if we lived together it
would just be like a border house like a
trade
it would be so people would come in and
be like are you okay
are both of you okay we'd be like no
we're not
i mean i think i'm fine but uh i can't
walk anywhere
um but do you guys have any
because you guys have been married for a
few years now right
six years i was like a child bride
basically i was married at 21. but
that's i mean if it works for you it
works for you i did you guys and so
you've learned to like grow and evolve
with each other and living together and
getting so many different like
life experiences
how do you guys for yourselves do you
have any like things specifically that
you do if you give each other like i
don't know the lists of can you get this
done or the best way to communicate
i think
it was a learning experience in the
beginning because he obviously came from
football so in the beginning he was like
full into football that was his entire
life so i kind of took up
cleaning which was out of my element and
doing all those things now that he's
done with football and he's focused on
his businesses
he and i both have a lot of free time to
spend together which is wonderful yeah
and i will give him props he puts up
with me
um
which is a big deal so both him and i
are so chill as human beings like even
talking about the hardest things yeah
we're like
flatlined type of logical people so i
think that that just helps us because if
i was somebody that was super emotional
they would hate me
they couldn't do it so i i teach the
right man because he is so stable which
is absolutely wonderful so anything that
goes wrong or goes bad we talk about it
right away we get it done and then we
move on i think that's the
like
foundational element is the
communicating right as it's happening
versus
oh my god i'm watching this person make
a mess and i'm not going to say anything
but it's going to build up inside of me
and then i'm going to explode yeah
no resentment is not cute you don't just
lose that you don't do it
um haley we're getting towards the very
end of the podcast
and uh before we sign off completely we
love to give a little token of our
appreciation to our guests that make
time for us and that is a personalized
horoscope from us to you that we have
created that melissa i think we'll put
in the chat for you
um if you if you're able to read that
aloud to the class
dear leo it's me
lion of the stars the ever asked the
ever-wise asteroid palace visits fire
sign
let's see aries from i have terrible
vision by the way so i apologize no it's
a bunch of gobbledygook basically aries
from mid-february to the end of april
for any challenges that may come in his
time just remember you work best as
either leader of the pack or on your own
thank goodness the nerd has yeah
yeah i love that so accurately
well then our star charts are aligning
um
haley where can people find you where
can they find nerd herd and everything
that you're up to if they don't already
know
so all of my social media tick tock
instagram youtube
everything is at h-a-l-e-y-y
e-a-y-l-e that's bailey bailey that's my
dad's nickname for me and then the nerve
heard is easiest instagram page that
we're launching the website's coming
soon and it's at the nearer
perfect uh go check it out guys this is
so exciting thank you so much for making
time and talking with us um i think
you're hyper fascinating and i cannot
wait to see what you do and to see you
in the victoria's secret runway show
very soon i'm sure
i know i'm like come on yes come on come
on manifest manifest
manifest
thank you for listening and watching uh
we'll see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep
not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music